by now most of you are almost certainly
aware of scp-343 from the outset he
appears to be an unassuming old man
although the specific details of his
appearance are subject to change based
on whoever happens to be looking at him
oh and he's also God we probably should
have opened with that or at the very
least scp-343 claims that he was
responsible for creating well everything
virtually the entire universe as we know
and understand it and even all the parts
we can't even fathom are according to
him the result of
scp-343's design it's that assertion
that earned him his nickname of God
among the staff of the SCP Foundation
well that and the fact that he can
seemingly do anything with as little as
a thought in fact scp-343 doesn't really
even need to think all that hard to
literally rework reality around him so
we might be wondering with virtually
unlimited reality warping power that can
enable him to do and be anywhere her all
the knowledge in the entire universe and
nothing but free time on his hands what
exactly does scp-343 do all day 6 a.m
scp-343 starts most days a week before
most of the foundation staff at site 17.
well to say he's awake before is
actually something of a misstatement
technically he can't be awake before
anybody because he never really sleeps
to begin with he doesn't need to not
only because he doesn't require sleep to
replenish energy like any mortal being
does but also due to the fact that
scp-343 doesn't exactly experience time
in much the same way as a human being
after all he did supposedly create the
very force of time itself rather than
living moment to Moment Like We Do
experiencing the present which then
becomes our past
scp-343 can exist at any and all points
in time at will for him the past present
and future are occurring simultaneously
although he seems to stay closely
tethered present but this is more out of
choice if he wanted to we're sure
scp-343 could be at every moment in
history probably even in multiple
different locations and even timelines
at once but that's just what happens
when you're the apparent original
architect of the universe and don't rely
on Ancient numerical systems and the
rotation of the earth in order to tell
time after being awake for all of what
we perceive as nighttime
scp-343 will go for a stroll nice and
early oh you thought we meant to stroll
around the facility he's kept at
no no no no no he'll take a stroll
anywhere literally phasing through solid
matter and sometimes even just
teleporting to whatever place takes his
fancy sometimes he'll choose a place at
random or pick an old favorite just
somewhere Scenic to watch the sunrise 8
am once the foundation Personnel have
had enough time to both fully wake up
and realize that scp-343 has wandered
out of its quarters then an urgent
search will undoubtedly be underway
Panic Foundation security teams will
start racing through the halls of
site-17 frantically searching for 343
he's not exactly trying to evade them
he's just naturally very resistant to
being contained it certainly makes
keeping up with him a challenge
especially when he walks through walls
and into the cells of other scps when
the security team does find him it's
inevitably because alarms are sounding
to alert them that another containment
chamber has been breached sometimes in
fact more often than not the staff
stationed at SCP site 17 will receive
word from another Foundation
installation that they've just seen as
cp343 stroll past security at a
completely different location sometimes
he'll pay a visit to scp-049 the plague
doctor usually casually conversing with
the anomalous physician and admiring his
surgical skills handling medical tools
is a tricky enough task made even harder
with a beak mask on your face on other
occasions the foundation has caught up
with scp-343 on his morning strolls in
various other facilities or with a
number of different anomalies often
he'll slip through walls to spend time
with scp-529 better known as Josie the
half-cat an otherwise ordinary
domesticated cat with anomalously
intangible hindquarters sometimes 343
will also pay a morning visit to scp-999
stating that he hopes the Tickle Monster
will be quote ready one day other times
scp-343 has been found by the foundation
sitting with Kane with the pair usually
being in mid discussion over some deep
philosophical pondering the pair of them
are rather friendly with each other as
if they've known each other for quite a
while with scp-343 on one occasion even
being noted as remarking to Kane it's
good to see how far you've got my boy
especially after all that nasty business
with your brother 10 AM wherever he ends
up once the foundation is able to catch
up with him they politely ask him to
return to his quarters back at site 17.
scp-343 is always amicable and will make
his way back post-taste usually arriving
before the security team who chased him
down are able to make it back once he is
back it doesn't take scp-343 long to get
bored however so he decides to undertake
a little bit of Home Decorating to pass
the time he's already conjured a
fireplace and plenty of elegant
Furniture into his room but on this
particular day he feels like adding some
color to brighten the place up with
little effort the Mona Lisa The Starry
Night the Persistence of memory Cafe
Terrace and night and plenty more of the
world's most famous paintings all
simultaneously appear on the walls
having summoned so many famous works to
his room
scp-343 has transformed his quarters
into his own personal Art Gallery he
spends a while studying the paintings
looking at the skillfulness that went
into the creation of each one every
brush stroke every color Choice he
almost seems like a proud father looking
at his child's art on display at a
school open house
scp-343 finds it oddly humbling to see
how human artists have reflected just a
fraction of the Majestic Universe he
created and all through such simple
means paint on canvas oil and water
brushes and an easel they seem so quaint
to someone whose preferred medium is the
very fabric of reality itself and yet so
many of the paintings he looks at seem
to show the world through an even more
beautiful lens imagination
scp-343 admired it naturally when
multiple art galleries around the world
reported that some of their most famous
works had all been stolen at the exact
same moment it didn't take very long for
that news to reach the foundation when
they were eventually able to determine
where the paintings were a squad of
guards politely told as cp343 that they
needed to be returned we've been looking
everywhere for them one explained with
as little as a blink scp-343 sent each
of the paintings back to where they had
come from 12 p.m at midday there was a
knock at scp-343's door from notorious
high-ranking Foundation researcher Dr
Jack Bright often whenever he was
working close enough to site 17 Dr
bright would pop in to visit scp-343
usually bringing along the anomalous
reality warpers preferred meal
hamburgers the pair would casually chat
to begin with enjoying their food while
a pair of security guards stood watch
outside however inevitably their
conversation would always take the same
turn you could remove it couldn't you Dr
bright asked referring to scp-963 the
amulet he wore around his neck or
nullify it somehow the enormous artifact
was bound to Jack Bright allowing his
Consciousness to be passed from one host
body to the next granting him functional
immortality although over time his
extend lifespan has felt less and less
like a gift and more like a curse
scp-343 had already been aware of this
thanks to them having the same
conversation over a number of years he'd
known Dr bright for longer than most
others working at the foundation and
knew how badly the researcher wanted to
die but every time as cp343 would deny
Jack's request Jack you know I could but
you won't the foundation doctor finished
the sentence why not will you explain
that to me because I know why you're
asking and why am I jack probed further
calm not raising his voice it's not that
you're tired of being alive for so long
although it may be how it feels
scp-343 explained but you only feel that
way because you're unfulfilled you have
this gift of immortality and what do you
use it for you work all you do is work
just because you no longer have the
short life everyone else has doesn't
mean you should stop living here you
devote yourself to the foundation all
its scps and Horrors go out and do
something for yourself every so often go
to a party meet people or make something
create a piece of art you could even try
making a movie what's the worst that
could happen that's why I won't remove
the amulet Jack because I want you to
have a chance to enjoy your extra time 1
30 p.m after finishing his lunch with Dr
bright
scp-343 takes some time out of his day
for recreation completely unbeknownst to
the foundation scp-343 phases out of
reality as we understand it and enters
an extra dimensional space an astral
plane some might call it while their
scp-343 likes to enjoy a game of
Solitaire Conjuring a deck of playing
cards from nothing and using them to
play Solitaire is a basic game and once
based on chance how easy or difficult it
is to complete rows of cards all in
their matching set is all down to the
random arrangement of the deck that
could be y as cp343 likes playing a game
like Solitaire he has the ability so he
claims to create or unmake any part of
the universe to go anywhere or to do
anything if he wanted to the cards could
always be in the perfect order for him
to finish the game in a few seconds but
where would be the fun most if not all
of scp-343's behavior seems to imply
that despite his Untold levels of
reality warping power he enjoys giving
up control or at least the illusion of
not having to control everything around
him playing with a completely random
deck of cards feels very much in line
with that aspect of his personality if
scp-343 wanted to he could always draw
the right cards he needed for his
solitaire games but then he would be
giving up that illusion of not having
control in much the same vein he could
very easily erase the universe's most
dangerous anomalies or even destroy the
SCP Foundation with little effort if he
wanted to and yet he opts instead to go
through the motions to let the deck of
cards stay in random order 4 P.M by the
time that afternoon is about to become
evening there's normally a bit of
commotion at site 17 all caused by
scp-343 given how large the SCP
Foundation is and how expansive the
organization's various facilities and
operations are inevitably someone who
hasn't heard about scp-343 eventually
learns of his existence when another
group within the foundation learns that
site-17 is accommodating a potentially
dangerous SCP with the ability to warp
reality on a completely unknown scale it
tends to cause a little Panic
requisitioning a mobile task force a
psych director from another facility
stormed into site-17 he demanded to be
shown to scp-343's quarters despite
protests from the on-site staff while
reassured the director that there was
nothing to worry about they had all
worked with scp-343 all can conversed
with him and knew him to be benevolent
but that just gave the site director
more cause for concern if scp-343 could
really do anything surely he could have
influenced how the Personnel at site 17
perceived him via some Cognito hazardous
means that meant they only thought he
was harmless bursting into scp-343's
room with the MTF Troopers the psych
director demanded that the powerful
reality warper explain himself by this
point this happened enough times that
scp-343 just used the sudden intrusion
as an excuse to leave the facility again
for a while he never even acknowledged
that the agents from another part of the
foundation were trying to confine him he
merely got up and walked away even when
the site director who was a far more
trigger-happy one this time around
commanded his men to open fire
scp-343 was unfazed the bullets from the
mtf's weapons had no effect melting into
nothing practically the second they
exited the barrel of their guns ignoring
anger shouts to sit back down and stay
put
scp-343 casually walked off disappearing
through a wall and leaving the site
director and MTF scrambling to track
down where he'd gone to Now 7pm The
Wider SCP Foundation was thrown into a
state of panic all while the
reassurances of the site-17 staff fell
on deaf ears it didn't matter how many
times they said that scp-343 would come
back in his own time the foundation were
already scouring the Earth looking for
the reality warping old man of course
few people think to look for you when
you hide out in a specific quiet Old
Town in Belgium
scp-343 had decided to take a
sightseeing tour of Europe while the SCP
Foundation attempted to track him down
every time he sensed that their agents
were nearby he vanished to another
Scenic location he enjoyed being around
people their lives were so short and
fleeting compared to his the novelty of
spending time walking among his
Creations never seemed to wear thin they
spent their lives spreading over
concerns that seemed so trivial to a
being who could see the entire Cosmic
scope of everything that existed and yet
it was these ordinary people who had
built great cities and civilizations who
had developed culture and art beyond
anything scp-343 could have ever
anticipated when he created them if he
actually did create them his tour across
Europe had brought scp-343 to Bruges the
oldest and most well-preserved medieval
town in Belgium he stood at the top of
an Old Clock Tower looking out at the
view of the buildings and the canal that
ran through Bruges he was impressed at
how long a place like this made by man
had stood the test of time an old man
came to join scp-343 having observed him
in the tower and thinking he looked
lonely the pair of them got to chatting
the reality warper revealed who he was
much to the man's surprise he found
himself believing the outlandish claim
that this stranger had indeed made the
whole universe the old man proceeded to
ask about about the meaning of life and
the universe what everything meant and
was for 42
scp-343 answered smirking still staring
out over Bruges the old man looked
confused oh that's just a joke from a
book I quite enjoyed 8 P.M
scp-343's sightseeing break did not end
in Belgium in fact it didn't even stay
confined to Earth for very long the SCP
Foundation the ones who weren't
stationed at site 17 were still on the
lookout for the reality warping old man
although they were still yet to turn
their gaze upwards without any Fanfare
nor any explosive teleportation
scp-343 just popped into existence
standing on the surface of the Moon he
basked in the earthlight for a while
looking at the view of the entire world
from here it seems so much smaller still
colossal in size compared to scp-343
himself but it was the distance
everything seemed so far away so
microscopic that for Immortal it might
be hard to comprehend but for scp-343 he
could see it clearly a world teeming
with life he turned his gaze to the
infinite expanse of space the whole
universe beyond stars burning against an
Inky Blackness as he stood looking up at
the solar system like someone admiring
their handiwork he spotted something
that surprised him a few million
kilometers from the Sun was an old
Volkswagen Microbus this was
scp-1958 a vehicle that had been heavily
modified by a group of friends so that
they could leave Earth and go travel the
cosmos together they'd initially been
successful and had planned to visit
Alpha Centauri a star system in the
constellation of Centaurus unfortunately
a miscalculation meant it would take
millions of years to reach their
destination ultimately the entire group
on board as CP 1958 had perished Lost in
Space while he was saddened to know of
their deaths thanks to his omniscience
scp-343 could hardly blame the group of
young friends for one to travel to the
Stars he might not have chosen to do so
in an old Microbus but he could
understand why they would go to such
lengths to fly away from Earth it truly
was beautiful up here in space
scp-343 thought 10 pm having decided
he'd been gone for long enough
scp-343 thought it was about time that
he should be making his way back to site
17. he'd given the SCP Foundation enough
of a run around for one day
scp-343 would finally settle back into
the comfort of his cell exactly where he
wanted to be want an anomaly of your own
check out scpswag.com for high quality
SCP merch now go check out what if
scp-343 wore scp-035 and scp-343 God vs
Bill Cipher from Gravity Falls for more
Explorations into everyone's favorite
anomalous deity